Finding a government that is more
responsive to,
uh,
to the real problems that we're having,
not just
politically,
but in terms of the globe,
the planet.
Um,
I don't have anything new to add to
this,
but
as someone said,
read the other day that if we do
something,
if we start doing something about
climate change now,
it'll be a lot different from starting
five years from now or worse 10 years
from now that,
um,
and I think people's minds are changing.
We've gone,
I think from some sense of alarmism kind
of a chicken little sense of the
planet's gonna Cook Up to 190 degrees
and we're all gonna die.
Um,
we've got the evidence just keeps
mounting,
which,
uh,
has resulted,
I think in a well growing consensus
that,
uh,
that yeah,
this is,
this is real and it's not,
it's not good.
Alternatives to war.
Um,
again,
when I was listening to a,
a talk earlier today,
which talked about lifting a Edm in out
of Uganda and placing them somewhere
else.
And,
and,
uh,
without destroying the whole country,
I mean a way of ways of neutralizing
dictators that are less or that are more
humane and less destructive than just an
all out war on the country.
Uh,
I think I'm a leader that would have a
more inventive sense of strategies
because we need some new paradigm in war
is sort of an,
it should be.
We should be over that,
that,
that old paradigm of just throwing our
youngest people into the face of,
of danger.